switch Mitchell brings it back the
jumper is
smooth Nets lead by four one possession
game 45 seconds to
go Steel by
Mitchell we're all tied up after the
slam and there was some confusion
earlier on off this possession and the
that's not going quick as quick as they
expected look at Donovan Mitchell with
the strong hands just rips it finishes
at the other
end Nets clinging to a two-point lead
they'll work it through Mitchell contact
with Johnson Mitchell for the lead got
him Cavaliers up by
[Applause]
one 12.1 on the clock and hits the J
tough one right there looks like there
is an extension with the arm Johnson
goes down but regardless shot goes
through it is still aive lot of time
left for Brooklyn you see right there
the left arm the question is how much
did he extend it and push off on Johnson
but overall Thomas on a bounce gets it
back from finy Smith 3 seconds two
seconds Thomas Hoy off the rim Johnson
no good the Cavaliers hold on for the
win on opening night